pure vendors trademark are elaborately
staged surreal worlds his spectacular
images like this famous one with a real
tiger shark unite arts and advertising
with each new project he opens a door on
a unique world soon the Baba's bag film
studio near Berlin will provide the
Danish photographer and filmmaker with a
venue to try out his ideas I want to
tell a story in one shot so this is
what's that i want to say but in my head
something has happened before something
will happen afterwards but I want to
tell the viewer the the one story in one
shot this is this is a little bit how
what is the general thing for my
pictures venture is planning a short
film his first project made in Germany
as usual he first develops his ideas and
then looks for financial backers the
preparations in Baba's bag are likely to
take nearly a year the whole idea is to
use the this stage is to build up a
world like a kind of a fake world which
still has a lot of reality to it and and
this is going to be the main scenes that
we're going to have roads here where the
car can drive through and all this kind
of thing for the first time an opulent
collection of photographs gives an
overview of his works over the past 30
years Pia vinta has advanced to become
one of the world's most sought-after
commercial photographers working for
brands like Nike Levi's dunhill or boss
he's not only shot photos but also
turned his ideas into films he's
received many awards including the comp
play of the Conlon's festival the Oscar
of the advertising world
his latest work is a commercial for a
Finnish vodka brand
there's always me building up a world
for this brand so it's not like the
typical kind of thing so you can always
say it's a little bit more like as an
art project would start you have an idea
and then this art project will have a
logo in the end for instance the car
crash picture the guy riding on the
shark you know from Levi its advertising
pictures of which we sell on the art
market because it has that standard so
for me it's very important to actively
say the advertising work I do has to
have that kind of level that you want to
hang it on your wall in the end and that
comes at a price ventas work methods are
reminiscent of big Hollywood productions
in fact that's where most of his works
were made up to 80 people are involved
in producing the perfect photograph the
elaborate sets require huge amounts of
money minta typically has a budget of
several hundred thousand euros like here
to photograph a basketball star dirk
nowitzki hanging from a helicopter every
protein is a challenge like one way or
another is like it's definitely easy
street I chose there after stays in Los
Angeles New York Paris and London love
drew him to Berlin six years ago as here
in studio Baba's back he often works
with artificial sets that artificiality
enables him to realize his new ideas
exactly the way he wants to
I also use it a little bit too to create
a little bit of picture give it a little
bit this off feeling that it looks
ninety percent real but there's ten
percent something not right and this ten
percent right right is that a little bit
what's gonna catch your eye vinta
reworks his photographs but he doesn't
manipulate them digitally that's a
matter of principle for him I built it
up the same way I always done for 20
years I have the car physically in the
studio or outside I have the people
standing in front of it and the
background so for production point of
view are more expensive to work with
because it requires a lot more money to
build it this way but I think it's also
much more rewarding and I think also you
can see where the picture is done for
real or not you know I think the people
it has another energy the pictorial
worlds of Kiev inta blurring the
boundaries of art and commerce